[Music]
hello everybody what's up good morning
oh good morning happy Monday that's
right happy Monday yes welcome back
thank you thank you
III was great time we're gonna talk all
about today I'm such a great time my
voice is still recovering so whoo III
all right well you know we also had this
like work karaoke Friday afterwards
which was like the nail in the coffin
for my boys so it's all good
well I hope you guys had an amazing
weekend hope you enjoyed all the e3
coverage on Persia today I'm here with
Curt greetings and that we're gonna play
some cadence of Hyrule which is a
basically a mix between crypt of the
necrodancer and The Legend of Zelda
so you kind of move to the beat move to
the music to get through all the levels
and everything like that so I'm pretty
excited to try it cuz I've never played
but I'm also a big zelda fan so great
and my big fan is beating right now oh
yeah like the remixes are bangers like
it got turned up the music a little bit
but yeah
cyborg man says happy Monday it's not
possible it is possible cyborg man it's
all good though
stream is lagging Robo voice no that's
just my voice it's not the stream
looking I promise
so we were originally gonna have Jordan
on so we are on his no it's fine your
Kurt your current own it own it so this
is Jordans Nintendo switch so we're
gonna start a new game so if you see
that there's a continue it's all good
I'm gonna let Kurt man the station while
I talk with you guys and yeah so yeah it
was - a new game the cool thing about
this is you can do a co-op but I want to
be able to answer your guys questions
while we play so maybe we'll do co-op a
little later yeah that's my excuse no
you got this you got this is this canon
in the timeline so from what I
understood from what I was researching
about this game every time you go in it
it's like a randomly generated world so
I think it's more about you know the
objective which is to move to the beat
and get through the dungeons and stuff
like that but feel free to correct me if
I'm wrong you guys I didn't know too too
much about this game because like I said
before I had never played crypt of the
necrodancer but Jordan he tried it out a
little bit so far and he said he's been
enjoying a lot so i'm excitedly world
house it's in its Elda what's not to
love about Zelda and when the best now
min display he said well thank you homie
right here Monday through Friday of its
11 en rageous this already like so good
to understand to the wise
yeah I'm always up there to restore it
but sometimes
I like this
they need a little extra
I know it was so edgy I know that in
confidence
it was crazy okay so you falling on your
face and now you hear hey hey you I saw
you fall from the sky
hey I've read this pick-up line before
[Music]
[Laughter]
but guys getting into the gameplay now
you guys and checking it out I'm kind of
excited to really see what it's all
about
cuz it's supposed to be to the groove
and something they emphasize a lot was
that all of the you know classic Zelda
tracks we loved have been kind of
remixed and now we get to fight to the
beat so for those of you asking what is
this game about you know it's a cadence
of Hyrule it's kind of like a mash-up
between crypt of the necrodancer and
Legend of Zelda so we're definitely
gonna get those bangers in there as
those the sweet tunes are on the way I
never also played the original crypt of
the necrodancer yeah exactly so that's a
little fresh for us as well so should be
pretty exciting is that this is for
switch CMS see my last
can you find something to help us I'm
stopped I see right there there right
there that's maker I've never played a
video game now it's all good it's all
good
there's so many games out there like
honestly it's really really hard to have
played everything or I've tried
everything
dude I ain't going there
guru that says love it already
I know right I'm already jamming and
it's like these are the lead up the lead
up tunes oh here we go
Oh
[Music]
yes I do whenever enemies are around
everyone is forced to move to the side
oh yeah I like uh-oh you missed the baby
okay so move to the beat by square there
you go I mean I'm like yeah do this I
actually have no idea but all I know is
we got some rhythm personally I have no
rhythm whatsoever so I would definitely
be bad at this game one time I went to
my friend's birthday party and we were
like at a club and I don't go clubbing
at all but we were at Club and I'm
dancing I'm dancing and my friend is
like it's not that you don't know how to
dance you just dance to a different beat
of the song
[Music]
you know that's what it was like mom say
to make you feel better
[Music]
so I see some of you in chat want us to
play link where I think in the
single-player mode you have to kind of
find a link and they are the other
characters to unlock them first so from
the start we can't really play them just
yet but I do think it's play the
two-player co-op mode you can actually
play us the other characters from the
start obviously because the other person
has to pick a character so for for right
now I think we have to unlock him first
link I mean and oh here we go yeah
should we do like first everyone wants
to see some link
oh just just to know it's Monday you
know let's give them what they want
they're just sleeping I'm gonna wake
them up real quick so chilled is back
welcome back and welcome back everybody
else all of our familiar faces
[Music]
[Laughter]
no you have to I knew you were a special
thank you for helping to Wiggly like it
was everyone in chats gonna fall asleep
at the time to get to these lines I know
some serious ASMR should I read this do
I have to read this um hey if you're
watching the VOD pause right here and
read this oh my alright look out dude
you should try to find your way home I
hope that can you hit can you tell how
many times I've done this I hope our
paths cross again someday soon friend
sounds like you're going to be busy for
a while
I'll be around looking for a way to get
back to my world I hope to see you again
oh so my link though yeah oh snap you
guys asked and you received we have some
link like so waiting I know toons says I
mean we can't break stuff no I guess not
you only fight to the rhythm that's weed
oh here we go
oh this is like Royalton I'm excited to
hear some Lost Woods remix not gonna lie
Lost Woods is probably one of my
favorite song because me being tired
like Zelda oh my goodness this rock can
you pull I don't know we can pull but we
need that Jill that's like when you go
bowling and they put the bumper come on
Kurt find your rhythm
I am the rhythm Queens
I'll get used to it trust me thank you
yeah you know we're just assaulted me
earlier being like okay oh nice I like
and then it kind of has the little meter
at the bottom so you can know when the
beat is coming that's nice
Oh
[Music]
what oh he's back oh he's back this is
so we need that shield there we go
so a stream how you been I bet you three
all week last week it's okay we're not
in beat mode right and I think you're
good no pressure
do you have to press the buttons on beat
or is it just every hop does its own
action or do you actually press
something too
every single time you move is with the
beat alright and then when an attack
comes out is that also just with you're
on B or so the attacks for what I
understand okay but for example with the
shielding Rock I had to hit my shield
gotcha
okay okay we're still learning here a
guy I thought that was that jigglypuff
we're just crossing all universe Josh a
jade axe okay first time here welcome
nice to see you
[Music]
you missed the chest and links house
Kurt wait
yeah so when I attack an enemy I don't
actually you just gotta hit the beep
[Music]
oh no yeah don't hit the chicken
oh yeah the chickens are a free man he
just broke the sacred roll so yeah I was
in here all week last week because
obviously III was going on but what was
your favorite thing about e3 or there
was too many things for there just to be
one what were some of your favorite
things at e3 Kurt and stream it's my
favorite I was working it so I didn't I
was hanging out with a lot of people
trying to get people onto this live show
the one thing I did get to play just for
a moment that was like that in control
were the things I really wanted to oh my
gosh that game was so good
well yeah he's tough we're also not on
beat
there we go I was
maybe you haven't unlocked something in
navy otherwise though favorite thing I
met suit at 51 I helped in oh my gosh
there were so many amazing things
actually that I'm super interested in
like I don't know fleeing like fallen
order looks so good
when I watch the gameplay I was like wow
this looks really good and it looks like
you can do all these really cool things
like oh no the water was too deep
I know you're on fire the apollon order
was awesome you know I I heard people
didn't really like you know what they
saw from the Avengers game but I
actually do like it because you know
they're not going MCU route which i
think is fine there's nothing wrong with
not going and see you route especially
when you know you have characters as
cool as Iron Man that if you did go MCU
out we wouldn't be able to use those
like right so I don't know I think
that's the fun of just comics in general
that there's all these different
universes so I think like people kind of
forget that so but you know time will
tell I know it's actually really close
it's really close crime asks if I got a
chance to play short and see a shield
and I didn't I was actually working the
base station all three days but I did go
snap that means you heard me at least a
few times
oh wise the I statements Ortonville yeah
yeah I didn't get a chance to play it
but I heard good things and they're
setup was super cute Oh
Timbo down interesting oh yeah now you
like yeah
Timbo up let's get back to normal Oh
it's like that's now yeah III was great
I definitely had a ton of fun thank you
for asking lurking zero it was great you
know this was my third III but it was my
first actually being a part of like a
big production and being somewhere I
would be like easy there we go Kurt
doesn't play baseball okay
he's a gamer
[Music]
just line all the up tempo and then oh
no you're badly hurt but don't worry
badly bad okay you may have left some
fragile Garant rupees behind these of
the rest of your items well gee thanks
Oh interesting
activate is the sheikah stones as you
can as many it will make things much
easier for you that's that is correct
a lute card reborn he says so this is
basically crypt of the necrodancer by
Zelda skins and music that is that it's
actually the perfect description yeah in
the Zelda mashup you know it's hidden
that's why how did you know let me tell
you that stream the stream knows all he
like move a chair or something I don't
know crimes like listen to the beat it's
there somewhere maybe hey didn't you go
pick up the shovel from over there I
said I remember oh you might have to do
it again because you died yeah yeah ah
see you guys the first time it's not
that he missed it he just went to go get
the shovel of hers it's exactly I know
what I'm doing it was over
don't help check that dark cave right
there yes shovel that is correct bunny
we like ended up putting mass killings I
was like you definitely picked a jump to
shuffle boom there we go that was
definitely on beat but easy easy the
telescope we could see further we've got
vision we've lifted the fog of war mmm
also I apologize guys my my voice it is
lost but one day it will be found
[Music]
I thought you would be doing nothing but
like night at the Roxbury head thing so
there's as I'm playing to try to keep
myself on beat
yeah this actually just came out you
guys last week I don't know if the guys
saw the mmm
the the Nintendo press conference but
yeah they leave a lot of stuff out for
us which is pretty cool
breath of the wild - on the way which is
like
[Music]
oh my gosh
the best meat boy in town
I can't go roomy as good as I'm pretty
good
Kurt walkthroughs dot TV oh snap they're
ready the stream ones your own
walkthrough channel hit the beat good
fun stuff that's the button there's the
shovel equip you know oh oh yeah yeah
you're right looks like walls I don't
know looks like dirt looks like dirt to
me games done slow these crimes Savage
if you're playing on a TV or monitor you
need to configure the latency of your
screen and audio setup if you haven't
already I could explain your missed
beats no I like the benefit of the doubt
though oh the lighter sand is the one
you can hit we were just looking at the
wrongs and aha see bunny love is helping
us tremendously right now
[Laughter]
okay the show we got settle down the
chicken these are fine the intro was
pretty hardcore rural metal to hit the
beat my form the song Oh DJ crud and the
house dogs
[Music]
I know my voice is robotic right now I
lost it
after a three week base station was
really fun though even though it was
outside and it was warm it was really
fun
hosted all three oh no we died again
Kurt you gotta feel the beat man the
music you gotta let it flow through your
home
those poor beats there we go we didn't
miss no beats there Oh Kurt I just don't
give me commentators curse when like you
know I'm commentating I say one thing
like oh that never happened and then it
happens immediately after no gosh she's
hopping toward you yeah let's get out
there alright we just gotta do that five
more times okay ow ow
Kurt's is anyone having a really good
time has everyone really feeling the
beat today it's Monday bunny love says I
played through this in like two days and
now I feel great emptiness Oh No well
now you can just watch me and feeling
even
and you'll even just feel good about
yourself that you can do it it's like
watching a Netflix series like once it's
over you're like why why did I rush it
down
oh my goodness if you got this there we
go don't hurt no you've got it
I believe maybe it goes that the music's
not loud enough here let's I got it feel
it you got it
yeah you just needed the the beats to be
louder tempo down don't destroy yourself
can you jump on it again let go slower
wow it does hey that's kinda helpful
[Music]
okay so I need to know how the stream
feels about Keanu Reeves men yo I was
insane and it was a wonderful so the
weird thing is my brain so like I've
been like I'm can a sweetheart I really
yeah I think that's how we all feel
yes so I've been like a long time huge
fan for is obsessed with the dude all
this weird philosophies and all
and I always I can't there's certain
roles I can't unsee him in oh boy which
ones I got a no so there's one in
particular that I always bring up
there's a movie called freeze that was
made by Alex winter who's the co-star of
Bill and Ted's Excellent Adventure
okay he's built and he play canneries
plays this uncredited dog manatee
and he's remarkable in it another movie
that think of is neon demon which is a
much darker movie and then Ken Ruth does
not play this oh my goodness however I
know he's amazing
I just I can't help I also feel like um
when we started talking about Carrie you
were hitting every beat we found the key
to Kurt success let's just talk about
Keanu gosh Keanu
he is breathtaking but I was very good
at DDR which is why it's so frustrating
I know right boy this game John Luke was
like I'm gonna try to play this game on
a DDR pad and I was like that's amazing
let me know if it works
you know I watched a trailer for this
and they made it look so easy and like
it doesn't look easy at all I'm just
gonna throw it out there oh there we go
that was a flawless attack right there
oh yeah look there's stories have rise
and Falls things happen we have to
overcome our problems and this is me
overtaking you've got my own just don't
forget your breathtaking ok kyani said
it we're all breathtaking soon we're all
gonna start stop breathing and we're all
gonna die see oh you're in the groove
now feel it
oh yeah we don't miss those beads ooh
did you see the combo up down oh snap ok
coming for him first boom plus one
vision radius let's go purple chests are
important alright we're placing a higher
priority on purple chest Thank You bunny
love bunny loves gonna be our
walkthrough help tell me what to do
every step of the way hit the beat
pickin up down down left right that's
enough
crime says its III videogame hangover I
know right it is pretty crazy so kind I
hope that's what you guys think okay
that was like the first time I
successfully block anything yeah there
we go
pooped onto the beat that's even more is
that as I mean it's Monday and we're
pooping the beats guys that's what it is
bunny love helmet oh there's a chest up
here show me the way AHA okay
we know this back where I'm at great
money love hey we go over there to left
somehow cuz I'm big ol cheese who
planted these the air okay all right we
need to jump up on the plane
pooping be open that's the newest game
announce that you guys have played y'all
have played beat Zelda y'all played some
beat Zelda games and you necromancer
beat games but have you ever played beat
poopin I know right Boop to the beat God
what has happened that is the next
install wait let me change this I mature
18% oh no think about Keanu Keanu you
know it's really pathetic but I wasn't a
drummer so let's just pick that up real
quick that's probably the greatest part
about maze hey that sounds like you
should definitely invade jamming out
right now there we go exactly I find if
you like bump your head so it's here it
helps also people like that one game
rhythm heaven and I was I was a type
where I could only play rhythm games if
it was a song that I knew religiously
for like a couple years before the game
even came out right like a rock band
came out and it was all like songs we
knew house like man I could do this oh
my lord they hit you with the mix-ups
was this one I have have you ever seen
me try to play like anything that's not
like a shooter or a fighter it's real
bad
it helps if you tap your foot so the
behavior is just I'm just tapping
everything whatever here we are we're in
this for the ride
crime asks why did we choose this game
well it was just released at the end of
a three last week this is our first day
back for GameSpot live first you know
after e3 and Jordan Hanna download it on
his switch already super kind of like a
perfect why did let me ask again
why didn't all right what's your
favorite game career I'll put that on
next time oh well good we can enlighten
the world and then show off your
top-tier super fine young blood oh yeah
that looks big I'd say four to come out
yeah well honestly you wouldn't have
been able to move in any other direction
except for off of it except maybe that
let's go inside somewhere I wish in real
life if like I walked outside and I was
like oh man that was a mistake I would
just go back inside and come back out I
go it's all been like playing this game
I wish they would come back
leave the room and come back if you like
it never happened okay that doesn't mr.
funny love you got no way there's
nothing up there oh I think I get it
okay
it's formulating it's happening the
gears are turning my simple crime says
have I seen air extreme fortnight and
literally dying one minute after
deployment for an hour and a half okay
for tonight is just like that sometimes
most battle Royales are just like that
most times Oh
yo oh snap stamina that's amazing okay
so
I gotta get there first though maybe I
should go change
yeah it looks shallow enough I even do
it do it do it
we're already piecing together every
puzzle here and we need that purple
chest remember priority what are they
you know I am good at stuff a game
honestly I feel like with the state of
like oh oh okay you're really over it I
think you're on to something there is
just like one more step we need it well
that's that's good though that's the
nature is a Zelda game it introduces
things to you and you can't quite this
together until maybe things later down
I see
yeah oh yeah oh yeah link please I
should have played this right that is
the real reason I was all good
oh yeah my Gemara we've unlocked though
yeah just let me go where you slowly get
in there
arrow castle protected by a October's
magic that magic
we need to find dr. strange but he's
been coming counter his magic oh my gosh
if you bumped you back Kurt I believe I
believe no I do believe is real this is
what we have to understand some people
are just good and I'm willing to own
accept and embrace I'm just simply games
are hard I don't need to validate my
game hood [ __ ] with fun toon jams you
know I'm saying when are we gonna get it
gonna get a battery out this oh boy it
was so funny when I was watching the EA
press conference and they were talking
about how following order was like a
single player action adventure and then
Greg was like they're still alive
everyone they're still alive and I was
like it's so true right everyone's
adding some sort of that means fallen
order happens to be good because if it's
not no it's real good a lot of looks
really good so far
hi everybody my hands and then we'll
find out I know I know I just want to
play it already
oh and I mean speaking of battery
although apex finally dropped some
updates they revealed the new champion
alright next up I'm gonna I'm gonna help
you out I'm gonna try to jump in and
everyone can watch me and suffer no next
death don't just run into it this game
ain't for the faint r is for patient
voice yeah exactly bunny love says I say
it's still not configured correctly for
it lately see well I really appreciate
your have faith in yourself funny thing
I took care of these [ __ ] okay until
I got to this [ __ ] over here and
then I got a poke him in a day oh boy
[Music]
my heart apart all right we need some
hail need some Hales no Oh a laser bu no
thanks
but yeah apex they talked about season
two they released a new champion Kurt's
nothing happened what is going on I'm
good good I mean for the most part
though like if I were to actually sit
down the male in a fireman and get down
with this game I think I could yeah I
think this would be for me personally
this is like a sweet afternoon I don't
all right let me give it a shot let me
let me see let's see no I don't want to
question my worst debut this is my first
stream with GameSpot and this is like
it's good you know one thing I've
learned since like streaming here is
like I play all these games that I've
never played before ever so I'm not
expecting like to be the best but it's
kind of fun you get to like try out all
right I really
out okay Oh No hi my Elf totally killing
it best gameplay ever okay I'm gonna
walk over here we're gonna go back to
the scene I also like bracing my where's
my shield
okay there's shield now okay a keen spot
we played games oh yeah oh yeah I mean
we're clearly not saving this show
I like how Jordan was like yeah you know
I played a couple stages of this oh
you're so you're a shooter girl your
fighter girl you do that stuff that's
what that's what that's what those those
your stomping grounds yeah it's a
different kind of song the ground thank
you guys thank you so much for welcome
you know I think we're both a little out
of our element but that's okay okay I
mean for me I'm a big fan of adventure
games and I'm a big fan
I like shooters and I like fighters a
lot too
I like I was you know like the DDR
champion of my that's a lie but I did
play a lot of DDR yeah that's right else
I'll own the new factor for this
pretty fun time but I mean that hurts
you no one knows you're killing it
I'm Jana's day on beat you're good but I
got to defeat all the enemies I can get
this purple chest Oh constant yeah
exactly
he's got to feel the beat
I'm trying really hard
oh I tried to attack him he's a good guy
those bloody dudes oh oh my goodness is
blocked
dude these blobby dudes yeah I mean I
have no rhythm whatsoever it's fine
I'm trying really hard though so now we
have Zelda crossovers crossovers with
everything God of War right Oh Zelda and
Master Chief yes Zelda Master Chief
I'm gonna die we have to have a Zelda
first-person shooter now I would never
want the belt of recruitment all I want
to see it link in all his glory way I'm
offbeat I feel like you know what I feel
like right now when you go to a concert
and they make the whole audience clap on
beat and no one can clap on beat to say
it what hey that's me pretty much then I
get all I need some help and go back
some bushes
yard you
[Music]
Wak pushes the name in the streaming got
here
okay I'm not funny at all but they let
me get on here anyway
oh man no get away from me yes yes they
changed up the beat I was just finally
getting used to the other one what did I
do
wait there's a game I think this culture
freaky chick does on the turbo graphics
many many moons ago which kind of had
like a similar vibe to this but it
wasn't so much I know just make me feel
worse
oh so we're the we need to get these
chica so we can warp them yeah that's
our way of being good parents so we can
go oh we gotta go up okay I hope
everyone's having a good time though
lipof blue
frickin be in there oh man I've been
watching black mirror and I go solve
along with all the B's I stood oh yeah
that's sexy
[Music]
yeah I'm er and give me this you take a
deep breath I feel you buddy
yeah I think the faster doesn't help my
hands are sweaty I'm sorry it's just
what happens to me no it's good okay
this is where you were I was gonna go
like oh I'm hoping the Lost Woods is in
here some rings that's my favorites all
designs it looks like we'll go next door
okay I believe in us know why we're
breaking down this gameplay here we're
getting better and better as we go on
[Music]
wait
[Music]
there is indeed a loss with section all
yeah we must find it Kurt in the
afterlife I love that they give us
unlimited lives because we would not be
able to do this I also just love that
bunny love this car the guiding light of
Pope oh my gosh
I'm still trying to like dis sight for
like okay each bee is a movement right
so it's like it obviously goes the same
for our dudes here so you gotta try to
move around them in a way that it gets
them to use their next movement turn
before your oh you can you can bomb the
wall undo that statue okay so I thought
[Music]
yeah I watch the trailer to this and
they made it look so easy so really not
uh uh what he looked like he hopped like
two squares it's cheating oh oh you sure
carrot please hey your guys still
jumping around no something on the floor
we got it I don't need anybody so bunny
lips says once you get a second time in
drop by defeating all the enemies on the
map you can buy the heart that she sells
then you can die slightly slimmer oh
yeah you got still it's okay I mean oh
he's at oh my gosh me oh oh my gosh you
got this Kurt oh he's got you cornered
we gotta get out wait oh my got stuck
okay so next time don't go in that
corner don't do it different enemies
have different attack advantages gotcha
so those guys probably did hop forward a
couple of squares it's like just a
little bit and kind of like you know a
little RTS action yeah yes beats a
little slower so now they're dancing
here we go come give me yeah it doesn't
help that neither of us have tried the
original crypt of the necrodancer so you
know a little bit of a learning curve
for us here
nay's slow and steady oh my gosh she's
close okay nice nice nice
so when he's swing and try to run try
gets to the behind him because those
three squares behind them yeah they're
totally up the beat was nice and slow
he's like oh we got this feeling good
we're gonna defeat this boss you just
get there first alive okay
wait how did one hint do two hearts that
was crazy yeah a little woosah deep
breath in through the nose out through
the mouth we got this I don't want to do
the fixed beat thing because know we're
prideful game rings here that was
perfect that was beautiful no if I did I
mean there's nothing wrong with fixed
beat you know but I've beaten the hard
games so there's a bomb over there I
oh it does to our hearts up massive
damage got this okay getting around in
two steps is not possible as it as it
from what I'm observing here okay so if
he's looking at you guys they jump
forward and then jump back yeah oh it's
just easy now he got this now boom okay
one more and we're good we're healthy
right now easy peasy
smack him oh okay it's fine one more
time slow and steady yes and we got the
diamond that's probably like nothing in
this game no now we can go get some
hearts we can get more health when
needed we need that health good job good
job you know once we download his
technique he was easy now we get the
purple chest but see I don't give myself
the patience
if I may be shine to our and only link
and cadence that one or Zelda because I
know there's three oh man
all right well success and hello favors
welcome no you're like you're getting
you're getting in the groove now for
real I think I needed it I needed a big
Betty boy exactly put me in my place I
needed to get that sick double you know
all the excitement okay now I feel like
I'm gonna die
oh yeah it's easy now yeah good question
bunny bunny help us woo yeah that shield
is top tier now Aaron Aaron look that's
a good job thank you guys thank you guys
when do I need to buy a new joy Kahn's
after playing this game to be honest if
the joy cones have not run out after me
playing hours and hours of touches 99
you you're probably pretty good I think
I've actually only had to charge my joy
Kahn's like I got a thing to talk
yo you click on to run away
oh you buy it when you die gotcha
which might easy on ya think oh wait
Zelda has a magic shield it blocks all
directions but uses mana that is a top
tier shield I need one of those oh no
your boots
wait okay nice okay okay guys we got
four hearts and this is good news okay
where should I go now sure hang out in
that area
can I see we're having we going haven't
got
you know we're making or we're making
wait so this thing yeah blows up and
then I have a chance that one ray guy go
up and around or maybe down to might
work
I was going out to last to you
[Music]
I don't think I can get across that way
no I'm gonna walk just like the old
fashioned a even it wasn't like Guitar
Hero where they get
I know right
I think they knew that people would end
up like butchering it a lot at the start
so they're like now we'll let you guys
slide and enjoy the tunes honestly from
software did make a rhythm game I would
love it I mean because I love from
software games so like that's why it's
so silly that I'm disaster isn't it
insane like how vastly different like
games can be you'd be super super good
at one game and then turn around and try
another game and it's like do I even
know what a controller is try to say
it's like everyone's got their jam
everyone's got this thing not yet at
least
I think it's nice to be reminded like
that there are other games out there
that you're gonna invest your time into
because sometimes I feel like with
shooters when I pick one up like no
matter really what it is I'm like oh
it's a shooter you know I kind of know
enough to hold my own you just destroyed
although the guy see I'm telling you
that boss gave you the power
yeah we need to move this rock over
somehow maybe we'll come back to that
maybe we need another block so push over
if you could pull a block see that would
be the next let's DLC out alright now
we're good oh yes easy Oh
easy and even try to beat it down a
little
okay so homeboy can't get past that
statue over there crime is like just let
me enjoy the song you got this
I mean Kurt has been destroying so what
no you're good you're good
that was a cactus
[Music]
Oh son is a bang
[Music]
this question mark thing messes oh it
confuses you a very amount of time so
maybe that's just there to mess you up
like a light
[Music]
I feel like I'm about to like go win a
championship or something listening to
this
[Music]
oh wow that give us more diamonds oh boy
over okay now we're groovin I thought
like we're getting close to the lossless
so for seeing this guy which is exciting
oh yeah that's true too you can watch
the tile states change on beat oh if you
make the enemies around over the
question mark they'll start to run away
from me - yes nice another tactical tip
from bunny love Thank You bunny love
holding it down for our our sanity
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay that's gonna be expert Kurtz blocks
it really yes beats all the damn boom oh
I could teach you how to dodge please I
could teach you how to dial
[Music]
and then someone's going in on the
guitar so long
boom
[Music]
see I would be a jam into like the
hard-hitting beats of these like
fighters on
[Music]
I've also been notoriously dubbed like
website chicks named from Seinfeld
Eileen the one who's like a bad dancer
I'm like that's me all the time I dance
that way oh that guy hopped a few
squares into his death
[Music]
all right so I'm covering some ground
I'm doing okay I haven't died yet no
where I'm one heart how do we not about
that heart left fine
dizzy bad news oh boy they're after you
Elaine there we go it's great we have a
diamond oh wait we need five we need
four more where okay so I feel like I
want to go back here but I don't didn't
know what I was doing I can't get in
here yet because
we do from October so we have a few
other places to head out though
Cory says I did some great dancing
all-caps thank you and he said sorry for
the cab seats just passionate well I
appreciate that very much
all right let's go find that fire a
weekly goal does you're right it's
Monday every Monday I tell everyone to
me a goal for the week okay so and it
doesn't have to be anything crazy I
gotta like you know go make a million
dollars it's just something small so
that when you accomplish it at the end
of the week
Oh Sonia forget it okay what is mine I
got to thinking because I didn't put
much thought into this until this moment
but I think my goal of the week is going
to be it's tough you know because it's
like you want to set something that'll
make you feel good but you don't want to
set something to impossible for only a
week's time so my whole thing is my
philosophy on all things really it just
just show up wherever it is you need to
be show up and just like kick it in the
teeth the best way you can for me this
is me showing up to a game that I'm not
good hey great getting better and better
so and yeah for what it's worth
oh snap so this dude Sheila's
let's see whoever that thing is okay so
whatever this yeah don't mess with that
oh it exploded that's okay you don't
have the hover boots so I think we might
have to go back over there something
good good please weekly goal yeah my
weekly goal okay this is gonna be a good
one my weekly goal is going to be to
come up with all the games and
everything we're playing this week on
GameSpot live and try to help promote
them ahead of time instead of just being
like hey guys five minutes before the
stream starts we're playing this game
like wouldn't it be nice to know an
Earthling before him I would like eat a
pizza that goal is amazing I had beeps
yesterday and I can confirm that's a
great goal eat more pizza okay is it
just me or is cold pizza just really
good I love cold I also like hot beats
are like fresh right when you order a
bun like it's in the fridge you take it
out the next day I love me some cold
pizza here this guy looks I feel like
he's very friendly oh I also have this
ok I'm sorry if I butchered your name
but he Kiko commie says my weekly goal
is to finally get my model of I'm gonna
tattooed loose now I'm gonna get a
tattoo exactly you're gonna eat a pizza
I'm gonna good
I love it well good luck getting your
tattoos I have one tiny little one and
you know it's a big deal getting upset
coz it's gonna be with you forever
oh snap so I know how it go yes bunny
and Cory they they are on the cold pizza
wave I really well bunny says that they
have leftover pizza I don't know if that
means that they like it cold but Cory
likes cold pizza so I'm about it oh I
see you can use the fan to hop over be
nice you activated him and made a bubble
watches wizard dude straining that's
great that's a good model does that
remind you you know if you feel like you
want to do something no you don't want
to you're going to silence a great motto
and yeah I got your name right sweet now
it's always scary you guys have such a
unique name I never want to butcher it
but hey lion man is after you
[Music]
I don't know unless
thank you oh wait
Oh
gotcha oh the light colored sand we
solve our shovel
other bits now okay nice oh okay playing
with fate this beats like also very
infants like real slow and low I know
he's like not attacking or anything yet
either so haven't figured out what his
mu over pattern oh he's just easy yeah
another diamonds boy right there
buoys guarding it though oh and the
boots he knocked your shoes off ooh my
fault I was like I'm gonna I'm gonna
tickle toes
[Laughter]
I'll just keep it's porn honestly that's
like the most beautiful I guess is
boogie-woogie around this town and
experience oh oh wait not yet but we are
in a forest e area so we might be
getting closer I really do want to hear
that always a ghost can't hit him ladies
ghosts in now you can craft the diamond
sword oh that's not helpful
oh this is nice too though
Corey says I'm assuming some of these
enemies are from the necrodancer
universe I'm gonna say yes because
although I have not played every single
Zelda I played a few but some of these I
don't recognize so they could either be
necrodancer or they could be from the
games I haven't played it yeah I think
bunny says that they're all from Zelda
except maybe the mushroom guys like the
pig guy you just killed yeah I know I
don't remember seeing it please oh okay
okay
gotcha
yeah that makes sense yeah I really need
a switch really bad because there's so
many games that I've been wanting to
check out or I know are really really
good I just don't have a switch and I'm
like I definitely want to play breath
with a while before it breath while two
comes out though
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
unless I'm you but then again we don't
know anything about this press it all
seemed cool really you don't know it
just looks great just and we are excited
honestly if I could expense one I
totally would I don't know how what the
process is on that but that would be
awesome but I use the one here at work
when I'm here thank you for joining
thanks Jordan I do like this one though
it's a little groovy spooky wish Oh
strong mushroom I love this little pig
guy cause he's like flailing in front of
you that's his attack
I'm just gonna go up to the people in
the office now
oh it is a seat but it is a wino they
said it with - well I mean but the
heavily actually I mean I know they said
it was - but sometimes it's yes is the
next breath the while it was like you
know a sequel but it's I still can't
really there's no I tell you get more
information so I get a title so I know
what's going on like it's this sort of
like well see it does say that and wants
to confirm that back now that I don't
believe you crime but you know I just
make sure I'm good at my I know it's
definitely like - but you know I know
there's still a lot of unanswered
questions
oh I see yeah oh no I'm finding missing
I think this is the Lost Woods but the
one based on link to the past not
ocarina like oakarina design was my
favorite zelda of all times so I
definitely like the
especially like its aesthetic but I mean
no dad came that's such a style now
we're this officially that's kind of a
bummer cause that's like my favorite
song oh we finally made it Kurt Stone
was right there I just completely blew
it
it's okay I know where I'm going now I
know how to get there so galaxy the
gadget you started playing Krypton you
just start playing Kripa the necromancer
oh nice how does it I mean yeah how does
it compare this compare from seeing this
cuz we neither one of us have played it
so like I went in totally blind into
this although I do think the concepts
are very cool if like murdered a couple
different shots like a puzzle and of
itself and a rhythm game and also a
combination and Zelda and it works if
something were like it's a rhythm
adventure puzzle game I'd be like well I
honestly think this works really well
and now that I've liked parties I maybe
that's be from software yeah it just
takes some getting used to
I've always said like it's extremely
hard to jump into a game that you've
never played before and I've only ever
really known like one or two people in
history who could literally just pick up
any game they wanted to and we're good
at it so that is so rare bombs unleashed
oh there it is yeah
[Music]
I just get there I was there it's fine
it's fine
oh my god there's wanted to get there
and get that unlocked yeah because now
we can work there exactly that's a level
that was really always they were having
a dance party they definitely were one
of the monsters was holding this maybe
you can use it
oh snap spin a tag heck yeah that's been
assigned to Elle alright you're gonna
hand out these elves real quick yes
alright now we're really now we're
really having some Zelda what is she
doing in here by the way she could be
out there helping me you're the one who
selected who you wanted to believe she's
like I'm gonna hang out in this cave and
just wait patiently for you to find what
was the from what was the game from
software it did and it was published by
devolver I didn't see it at this 83 oh I
think you're referring to the mech one
they made which was don't call me I'm
picking pieces of this I believe that
was like the one of the first major
titles they did that's kind of like
working this way down the pipeline to
get to the distribution due to their
obvious I've never played it
Daniel says you guys should play read
that to online we actually did play read
that to you online not so long ago it's
pretty fun
me and Ben plated when they had the
update and play some poker and did
submissions it's a good time it's nice I
definitely wouldn't be mad at playing
again no you got this we still have 12
minutes yeah it's perfect very is like
this and all these days are just to come
in here the shake their junk
aye-aye-aye aye-aye-aye oh wait a minute
oh so we're in the Lost Woods so I'm
gonna be sitting my desk all day like
thinking about this boy where yeah
that's preachy diagonal sheet right
squishing oh yeah
Oh camel and he gets to actions are a
few actually
[Music]
go get that blade go get that bad boy
yeah yes okay back to slow and low cave
music look at this guy
he's too much happening no you dropped
your shovel oh no we have a mommy he's
cute as heck though that's okay we have
more health okay to answer your question
about the enemy types somatically they
are from Zelda but they use the moves
from crypts of the necromancer in make
sense makes sense will this be on Steam
not too sure I know it's on a Nintendo
switch right now yeah so switch
exclusive kiddies I mean in jindo i
think totally kills it this year they
announced a ton of games and I like it
made me want a switch even more because
of all the cool stuff yeah like they're
doing developers and people they're
working with we feel like it wouldn't
normally
I don't know how that's gonna work cents
on the switch but that's the thing
that's happening super excite for no
more here's three that's I mean we've
always sued it was on stage kind of
switch so trying you something
animal crossing about oh yeah what now
sighs swirls like I'm up on the stage
floor if we don't get a picnic or
announcement do that I'm sure everyone
was happy we didn't but we did get
Luigi's Mansion three for some of those
for some of you you're like yeah
whatever for me it's like Kim is like
what you don't have a switch I know it's
horrible it's sad but I'm also poor so
you also work here exactly right that's
almost like owning one except Norvin but
my birthday's coming up if anybody wants
to be a kind soul okay I got nice yeah
there we go like we're looking for the
man
[Music]
but yeah hands down definitely do need
to get a swig so many good games coming
out and they have like a ton of fighting
games on switch now school girls gonna
eventually be on switch and I'm super
stoked for that yeah what fighting back
with interest
duly noted what fighting games are you
super pumped for the switch skullgirls
hands-down I'm less like patiently
waiting until they announce that one cuz
that's gonna be really really fun I know
they have like is an MK on there and and
uh Dragon Ball so you know they got a
few that's right
and yes crime I mean it'll happen
eventually it's okay I'm a huge pigment
fan and banjo banjo but the bin people
like banjo man that announcement looks
super hate and I watched all these
reaction videos from people in Japan
when banjo kazooie yeah they were super
ready for that it's gonna be cute
[Music]
slow down a little bit see you're on and
I haven't seen you miss oh well don't
ski Kurt I didn't I want to slow it down
yeah
the slow down ones are tough I feel like
the speed up is good yeah
oh my god more good
Oh Kota sim case not that good on switch
[Music]
yeah for what it is I think the way it
plays is great it doesn't look great
mmm I see yeah I did that's what I pray
I know it's weird that's what I
primarily played it on because I bought
it right as I was moving here and just
like you know what I'll just be on the
switch I'll deal with it but for what
it's worth like I had a pretty solid
experience with it but I also am NOT
rain see him you know people will like
just write it over graphics and I'm just
like Mortal Kombat a switch like it
played well like for what it was like
hey it happens like making games is hard
that's something people don't realize
either like you know cut the wait codes
work and stuff like that you could fix
one thing and it will accidentally
destroy something else that he didn't
even like mean to do but you know it's
difficult hired that's why people are
constantly making updates and hot fixes
and stuff like that and then like to
transfer it to a whole different console
man and that takes some some real work
and effort so okay well you have four
minutes to destroy this room you've got
this with half hour all that sounds so
sad like you only I have a heart oh my
goodness hmm okay we can make it back
there four minutes
full health and then just destroy the
[ __ ] having it then let me try and
sneak into it a little few places
[Music]
oh this is where we were getting stuck
last time I was there y'all go up this
way covering some ground this is you
know you know you've been you've already
like gotten familiar with this and
you're grooving you're looking good
it's just as a timer I'm like the chest
defeat all enemies before oh boy
okay all right Ricardo says I'm also
gonna butcher this saludos from Chile
well hello welcome thanks for tuning in
all the way from Chile love to have you
guys in the stream for the shovel you
picked up does it have durability good
question right I know there's like a
little bar under it and the more you use
it the bar it goes down okay oh that was
that whoa wait where'd your timer go
already no way the fastest 70 seconds
ever
bunny love said you went from why did I
agree to play this to seemingly to
actually be enjoying it oh my gosh this
game was released this past Thursday on
the 13th so if you guys are enjoying it
so far go check it out it's for the
switch and yeah this was made by the
same people who made crypt of the
necrodancer it's kind of a mash-up
between zelda and crypt of the
necrodancer um so it's really cool and
the beat system is like you have to move
to the beat you can see the squares on
your field of vision pretty much and
then as you move to the beat you know
you can either move or I'll do an attack
automatically or yeah we can end it
there though because time is up it is
12:30 but that was really fun I actually
think this game's super cute some groan
no able to do some stuff I took down
that one guy that was like the highlight
yeah the boss easy-peasy
it was great so um thank you carrot for
joining me and thank everyone in the
stream for tuning in if you liked
cadence a viral go download it it's
available now on switch and just enjoy
dance to the beat and we'll see you guys
next time tomorrow I love ya
peace out bye this button
[Music]